(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) O termo que nós vamos estudar nessa aula
é hipoteca, então vamos ver o que é
uma hipoteca e qual a consequência prática de
existir uma hipoteca no leilão judicial que você
está analisando.
Hipoteca.
Hipoteca é a operação na qual se coloca
o imóvel como garantia para o pagamento de
um empréstimo.
Geralmente esse empréstimo tem juros menores e prazo
mais longo.
É uma forma de garantia real.
Por que a gente fala que é uma
forma de garantia real?
Porque especificamente um bem do devedor está garantindo
aquela dívida.
Então a dívida recai sobre um bem específico
do devedor, por isso é chamada de uma
garantia real.
A hipoteca, ela necessariamente tem que ficar registrada
na matrícula do imóvel, exatamente para dar publicidade
sobre a existência dessa hipoteca.
A gente já está cansado de saber aqui
no curso que a matrícula é um documento
público.
Basta que qualquer um requeira ao cartório de
imóveis que vai ter acesso àquela matrícula.
Então para você saber se existe uma hipoteca
ou não em determinado imóvel, é só você
olhar a matrícula daquele imóvel.
Necessariamente a hipoteca para ter validade contra todos
deve estar registrada na matrícula do imóvel.
O prazo máximo de uma hipoteca é 30
anos.
Chegando a esse prazo máximo, a hipoteca perde
a eficácia.
Para que a hipoteca continue valendo, vai ser
necessário reconstituir o contrato e nessa reconstituição vai
ficar expresso um novo prazo para a hipoteca.
Porque aquela hipoteca anterior, ela já não vale
mais.
Caso o pagamento dessa hipoteca não seja feito,
o credor hipotecário, que é a pessoa que
empresta dinheiro para outra pessoa.
De um lado temos o credor hipotecário e
do outro lado o devedor.
Então, para que o credor hipotecário possa executar
aquele valor, ele possa realmente fazer valer a
garantia que ele recebeu daquele imóvel, nomeamento da
hipoteca, ele deve recorrer ao Poder Judiciário.
Ele não pode fazer isso de outra forma
automática.
Uma vez que ele recorre ao Poder Judiciário,
a execução vai recair sobre o imóvel dado
em garantia.
O que significa?
Significa que o imóvel já está ali, ele
já foi dado em garantia.
O credor hipotecário não precisa buscar mais bens
do devedor.
A execução vai recair preferencialmente sobre o próprio
imóvel que foi dado em garantia.
E aí você pode estar se perguntando, nesse
exato momento, qual é a diferença entre hipoteca
e alienação fiduciária.
Afinal de contas, os dois têm o imóvel
dado como garantia para o pagamento de uma
dívida.
Então, qual é a grande diferença que existe
entre a hipoteca e alienação fiduciária?
A alienação fiduciária, como a gente já estudou
aqui de forma exaustiva no curso, o módulo
2 inteiro é dedicado a entender o que
é um contrato de alienação fiduciária e as
consequências desse contrato, ela implica na transferência de
propriedade do imóvel do devedor fiduciante para o
credor fiduciário.
Então, o devedor fiduciante, para conseguir um contrato
de alienação fiduciária, ele vai transferir o seu
imóvel para o credor fiduciário.
E essa transferência que possibilita que o leilão
extrajudicial seja realizado, como a gente já estudou
em todo o módulo 2.
Na hipoteca, isso não existe.
Apesar de existir uma garantia de um bem
imóvel, não existe essa transferência de propriedade.
Então, a propriedade continua sendo do devedor.
O credor hipotecário não tem a propriedade daquele
imóvel.
Tanto é que se o devedor ficar devendo
ao credor hipotecário, o credor hipotecário não pode
se valer de um leilão extrajudicial.
Para que ele leve aquele imóvel a leilão,
para que aquele imóvel vire dinheiro e ele
possa receber o valor que ele emprestou ao
devedor, ele deve recorrer ao poder judiciário.
E como a gente já estudou no caso
de alienação fiduciária, o banco que empresta o
dinheiro para o devedor fiduciante, ele não tem
que recorrer ao poder judiciário.
Ele mesmo vai fazer o leilão, que é
uma modalidade de leilão extrajudicial.
Então, no caso de hipoteca, o banco, para
rever o dinheiro que ele emprestou, ele pode
requerer ao poder judiciário que o poder judiciário
leve aquele imóvel que ele recebeu em garantia
a leilão, para que aquele imóvel vire dinheiro
e ele consiga receber.
Na alienação fiduciária, o banco não precisa fazer
isso, porque o banco, no momento que é
feito com a alienação fiduciária, ele já recebe
a propriedade do imóvel, a chamada propriedade resolúvel,
que a gente já estudou.
Então, caso o devedor fiduciante não pague o
que o credor fiduciário deveria receber, o próprio
credor fiduciário já leva o imóvel a leilão
diretamente, sem precisar do poder judiciário.
O credor fiduciário vai fazer o leilão extrajudicial.
Qual é a consequência de existir uma hipoteca
no imóvel que você está analisando?
Vamos ver aqui o que fala o Código
Civil.
O Código Civil, no artigo 1499, coloca as
hipóteses que uma hipoteca vai ser extinta.
E no inciso 6, o Código Civil fala
que a hipoteca vai ser extinta pela arrematação
ou adjudicação.
A título de curiosidade, o que seria adjudicar
o imóvel?
Seria o próprio credor ficar com o imóvel
como forma de pagamento.
Então, o credor não escolhe levar o imóvel
a leilão.
Ele poderia adjudicar esse imóvel e ficar com
esse imóvel se o valor da dívida for
igual ao valor do imóvel.
Aí ele teria essa faculdade de ficar com
o imóvel e não escolher pela venda do
imóvel em um leilão.
O Código Civil continua no artigo 1501.
Ou seja, o que o Código Civil fala
nesses dois artigos?
O Código Civil fala que a arrematação pode
extinguir a hipoteca.
Mas o próprio Código Civil já fala qual
é o requisito para que a arrematação tenha
esse efeito sobre a hipoteca.
E qual é o requisito?
O credor hipotecário deve ser intimado do processo
e do leilão que vai acontecer.
E se ele for intimado, tudo bem, o
juiz vai determinar o cancelamento da hipoteca.
E quem determina o cancelamento dessa hipoteca é
o próprio juiz que determinou que o imóvel
fosse a leilão.
Porque essa hipoteca não nasceu de uma vontade
do Poder Judiciário.
Ela nasceu de uma vontade particular entre as
partes.
Do lado um credor, do outro lado o
devedor.
Então, o juiz que determinou o leilão vai
determinar o cancelamento da hipoteca desde que o
credor hipotecário tenha sido intimado da existência do
processo e da existência do leilão.
Então, se o credor hipotecário for intimado do
processo e do leilão, pode oferecer o lance.
Se o credor hipotecário não for intimado do
processo e do leilão, não ofereça o lance
naquele imóvel.
Porque aquela hipoteca não vai ser cancelada e
vai sobrar para você como arrematante.
Então, tenha em mente que se o credor
hipotecário foi notificado do processo e do leilão,
a hipoteca vai ser cancelada sem maiores problemas.
E aí, como é que o credor hipotecário
vai receber o que ele tinha direito?
Afinal, ele tem direito a receber algum valor,
né?
O credor hipotecário vai ter que recorrer a
outros bens do devedor para conseguir receber o
valor que ele tinha direito ou se habilitar
a participar do chamado concurso de credores, que
é aquilo que a gente vai estudar mais
à frente.
Então, dentro da ordem de preferência de quem
deve ser pago primeiro, em um desses campos
vai constar lá o credor com garantia real.
E o credor hipotecário é exatamente um credor
com garantia real.
Porque, como a gente já estudou aqui no
começo dessa aula, a hipoteca é uma garantia
real.
Eu deixei aqui no último slide um exemplo
de uma hipoteca registrada no imóvel.
Então, veja que quando a hipoteca é registrada
na matrícula de imóvel, ela vai trazer todas
as informações daquela hipoteca.
Ele começa com a data, que essa hipoteca
aqui foi 15 de outubro de 1990, foi
feita por um instrumento particular, bota de um
lado os nomes do proprietário, que hipotecaram ao
Banco Bradesco.
Para a garantia de uma dívida, ele bota
o valor da dívida.
Repare que essa dívida aqui, de 1990, ela
é antes do real.
Ela está registrada em cruzeiro.
Tem o valor total da dívida, qual é
a forma de pagamento, qual é a incidência
de juros e todos os detalhes da hipoteca.
Como eu falei que a hipoteca tem um
prazo máximo de 30 anos, essa hipoteca aqui,
chegando no dia 15 de outubro de 2020,
essa hipoteca vai ser extinta automaticamente.
Nem precisaria constar na matrícula do imóvel algum
termo averbando o cancelamento dessa hipoteca, porque ela
vai ser cancelada pelo simples decurso do prazo.
Quando atinge 30 anos, ela é cancelada automaticamente.